you guys need to respect the beyonder  check this out so the beyonder has  omnipotence meaning he has the ability  to do anything including reshaping  reality and manipulating time and space  he's omniscient meaning he has complete  knowledge and understanding of all  things he's Immortal and cannot be  killed he can teleport himself and  others anywhere in the universe he can  manipulate and control energy including  the energy of souls he can reshape  matter and create new forms of matter he  can bend reality to his will including  altering the laws of physics and even  creating New Dimensions he can read the  thoughts of others and communicate  telepathically he has the ability to  heal others by channeling cosmic energy  and he's immune to mind control and  psychic manipulation make sure you guys  follow for more